and now for a drink you can sip on while
watching those new movies liquor lineup
the sponsors of this segment are showing
us a seasonal cocktail for the win
Welcome to our shop I'm Solomon I'm here
with Nick Nick what do we have for our
liquor lineup today well today we are
making a black raspberry margarita which
is the perfect cocktail for your next
Halloween party at home sounds scary
good all right so we're gonna start with
some heredura tequila I'm using the
herradora silver so while it looks like
a silver it's actually aged for 45 days
which is why it's a little bit almost
like a pale straw color as you can see
um next up we're going to add our
margarita mix you want to do about an
ounce of that
optional urugave mix you don't have to
put that in there if you don't want to
but some people like it sweet that's
definitely optional last but not least
we have our beautiful lovely Chambord
black raspberry liqueur that's a great
ingredient though and by the way all of
these ingredients download our app
liquor lineup and you can purchase them
and we offer daily delivery can I shake
yeah let's do it
all right and you're going to garnish
this with one black raspberry and or
blackberry and a lime
anyone serve this over ice and you have
yourself your next Halloween cocktail
amazing I'm excited to try it can I let
me know what you think
[Music]
phenomenal guys come down to our shop
download the app and come down here
maybe you'll get to meet Nick yeah I
love hanging out here
thank you liquor lineup for sponsoring
this segment they're located on North
Decatur Boulevard in North Las Vegas for
more information call
702-616-0311 you can also visit
liquorlinup.com or check out their app
liquor lineup to all make it all easy
for you you can also scan that QR code
right there on your screen Las Vegas now
we'll be right back
[Music]